some breaking news ET can confirm
basketball legend Kobe Bryant is dead at
the age of 41 the former NBA star
reportedly died after his private
helicopter crashed around the LA
neighborhood of Calabasas the LA County
Sheriff confirms five people died in the
crash
Kobe's wife Vanessa was not on board
according to TMZ Kobe and Vanessa shared
four daughters Natalia
17 Gianna 13 Bianca 3 and Capri 7 months
Kobe played his entire 20-year career in
the NBA with the Los Angeles Lakers
winning five NBA championships with the
team he was also an 18 time all-star 15
time member of the all-nba team 12 time
member of the all defensive team and was
named the NBA's most valuable player in
2008 et was with Kobe for all his major
milestones including when he retired
from the game in 2016 last game of his
historic career he was that the perfect
Hollywood ending how was it I didn't
even need a rewrite it was perfection it
was absolutely surreal but you know what
he deserved all of it just he's just
given us such incredible incredible
highlight reels one after another Kobe's
brought a lot of us joy his greatness
and his devotion was never in question
yes the night to celebrate what he's
done and white done for his town David
Beckham and his son Brooklyn were
courtside so were Adam Levine and Behati
Prinsloo who enjoyed a super casual
pre-baby date night some of those
courtside seats were being sold for a
staggering twenty seven thousand five
hundred dollars and you know there was
no way Jack Nicholson would miss it my
son's 24 that's what he was saying he
came to his first game here when he was
four years old with go
it's been a great experience and Kanye
well he was like a kid in a candy store
so excited about the Laker legend kanya
how incredible was that that was great
that was great I'm not doing our
interviews over that was great man how
beautiful I wanted to say
congratulations on a legendary
outstanding career Taylor Swift was one
of the many tape celeb shoutouts
including Justin Bieber and Justin
Timberlake
we're retiring now and I'm self-employed
so I get to keep him on our shoes
you tell me celebs took to social media
to pay tribute to the basketball legend
Dennis Rodman tweeting devastated to
hear the news on my friend Kobe Bryant
passing prayers go out to his wife
Vanessa and his children and the Lakers
family Tristan Thompson wrote quote I
hope this isn't true man not Kobe and
Drake sharing this pic on Instagram
alongside the caption it can't be stick
with et as well be tracking this
developing story
[Music]